[Music]
so now we already divided the board into
four sections the kingside White's King
side white blacks King side blacks Queen
side whites Queen side okay we're doing
really really good have you ever heard
the expression the Chess Center the
Chess Center you you you put your pieces
in the center of the chessboard because
that's where they're most effective well
we say that there are 16 squares in the
center ok these squares right here these
squares make the center so this is a
center square d4 ephors the center
square is f6 the center square yes
c6 is the center square f3 g3 no ok so
when I was a kid and I started playing
chess man did I lose so many games I got
beat so bad I didn't even know what a
draw was I didn't even think a draw was
possible I just kept losing losing
losing and then I came across a book the
book was called how to open a chess game
and I thought this is perfect for me
because I didn't know how to open a
chess game and the book was written by
12 grandmasters that very best players
all over the world 12 different authors
and each and every one of those authors
had their own approach to the opening
but you know I read each one and they
each had a different opinion but in fact
they didn't they all said the same thing
they said there are three things
only three things that you need to do to
open a chess game well the first thing
they said was you have to fight for your
fair share of the center which means
that you had to do your best to try to
control these 16 squares in the opening
that was their first principle their
second principle was that you needed to
develop your pieces two good squares
that was principle number two okay and
the third principle and it was very
important was that you needed a safe
king okay that was all you needed to do
was control the center develop your
pieces to effective squares and a safe
King that's all of our goals so I
started this was like wow now I
understood what I be free you know what
I used to do in my imagination when I
was a kid I thought of my rooks because
I was the general remember remember I
thought that my rooks were cannons whoo
those are pretty powerful pieces and I
thought of my nights as cavalry and I
thought of my bishops as archers and I
thought my King was weak he always got
checkmated so of course he was terrible
and that Queen well she was just my my
favorite but when I started I didn't
realize that the Queen was going to be
my favorite piece I thought the rooks
were really good so I used to start like
this for that was my opening move does
that control the center not even close
right you know what my opponents did
because they knew what I wanted to do I
wanted to bring my cannons out they
would play d5 you know what I did
developing my cannon is that a good move
that's terrible move right you know what
my opponents would do they take my rooks
they took my rooks I was like oh I hate
that when they do that well now I was
very clever I didn't take his archer no
no no I had to develop my other cannon I
played here do you know what my
opponents would do now they should
retreat the bishop they should go away
with the bishop and they'd be a rook
ahead they would play here and you know
what I did yes I develop my cannon you
know what they did hey rook I mean it
was like they didn't miss a trick you
know they would take my I'd lose my
rooks right off the bat so you know I
was a terrible terrible player so if
this was my early start to chess you
could see how why I lost every game I
play baby right so it was a revelation
it was a revelation to me that I should
learn to control the center so I came up
with what I called my fortress my
fortress position and the fortress
position I started as white with this
move Knight at 3 is this a good move
yeah because it controls the center it
develops a piece off the back rank we
can think of our back rank as the
barracks okay all of our all of our
soldiers are are at the barracks and
you've got to mobilize them and bring
them into the into the battle so Knight
g1 f3 is a good
because it mobilizes your pieces off the
back rank and it controls the center it
didn't really matter what my opponent
played if my opponent played this I
would take this pawn so that mattered
but if our pump my opponent played this
move or this move or this move showing
how clever he is right to copy me
I didn't mind so let's just say my
opponent played this move is this good
move it controls the center so that's a
pretty good move and then what I did is
I did this what do we call this when we
put our bishop yes the end shadow of the
bishop I loved to fianchetto the bishop
and it really didn't matter what my
opponent did I would put my bishop on
the long diagonal and it really didn't
matter what my opponent did i castled
okay and this is what I call building a
fortress so in the first place this
bishop is a loyal defender I kind of
thought of my bishop as my Royal Guard
so my king is royalty and the bishop
defends my king and this formation I
called a fortress because it was very
hard for me to get checkmated I lost
instead of losing in five 10 or 20 moves
I lost him 40 moves 30 50 moves I was
good I was getting better by having a
safety for my King so the first
principle was to control the center
second principle put your pieces on good
squares third principle a safe king so
this met the criteria of my pieces and
safe King now only now once my King was
in safety did I turn my attention to
controlling the center so for example I
also I also thought of my bishop as
as an archer in ambush right it's just
waiting for something good to happen on
this diagonal so in this position let's
imagine that black plays d5 is this a
good move yes it's excellent move black
is doing pretty good
he's occupying the center this pawn on
d5 controls efore and c4 this pawn on c5
controls what square in the center b4 b4
b4 correct this Knight controls what two
squares in the center and this knight on
f6 controls what two squares in the
center come on I didn't hear an answer
d5 in e4 okay so my opponent is actually
opening his position very well he's
controlling the center
he's also occupying the center and he's
developed his knights two good squares
so now it's my turn my turn to attack in
the center and I would play this move d4
is this a good move in terms of
occupying the center yes because it's a
move in the center and my opponent would
take my pawn I would take his pawn and
my opponent would play e5 attacking my
knight so what would I do
Knight takes c6 that's exactly what I
would do
correct bee takes c6 so my opponent has
played really very well he's got he's
occupying the center his Knights on a
good square his is this king and safety
not yet not yet
and my bishop is on a pretty good
diagonal correct it's on the long
diagonal but this pawn on d5 how is that
palm protected like a c6 pawn by the f6
and I attack that pawn with my bishop
and my queen is there a way I could
attack this pawn some more what would I
do
[Music]
that's that's one move but if I bring my
night out right away I can't really take
this pawn with my night because the pawn
protects it so what I would try to do is
I place full does this move play in the
center yes it does
yes it does and my opponent what would
happen if he advanced his pawn what oh I
was so happy about that that Bishop
remember I was telling you it was
lurking in an ambush Bishop takes c6
check I'd win upon and what happened if
he defended his check back yes because
I'm now at this time in my career I was
beginning to think that the canons
always got captured by bishops and now
it's true we can see it's true so let's
go back to this moment I have just
played the move c2 c4 and my opponent
would play Bishop e7 okay now what could
I do
how can I increase the pressure on the
d5 pawn how Knight to c3
you guys are guessing my moves and once
you know that you should be playing in
the center that you should be developing
your pieces two good squares a lot of
these moves start to come naturally they
weren't natural for me when I was
starting everything was really really
hard and difficult but once I understood
the principle of playing in the center
putting your pieces on good squares and
king safety my play I went from like
zero to like a thousand like just room
we were straight up it was an elevator
ride to the top I could I didn't even
think about 1200 that was just too too
high so if my opponent advances what am
I gonna do I'm gonna snap that pawn with
check so my opponent would defend his
pawn on d5 with his Bishop was that a
good move that's excellent move he's
bringing his he's developing his army
and he's centralized his Bishop and he's
protecting his pawn now I cannot take
take take take take take take because
I'm the end I'm gonna lose I'm gonna
he's got that pawn defended more times
than I can attack it how can I attack
his pawn some more how he four okay but
if I played this move I have a problem
what happens to that beautiful Bishop I
block my big it gets blocked darn and he
could move and I can't play Bishop takes
anymore so I shouldn't block my Bishop
but how can I pressure this pawn
some more does this night defend this
pawn yes can i attack his knight
how could I attack his knight right
developing my bishop attacking his night
which is defending his pawn
if black advances the spawn nothing
changed I just jump on that c6 pawn
right okay so what happens if my
opponent at last my opponent's been a
little bit slow but he's brought his
King into safety but now can I win
material can i yes what should I do okay
Bishop takes f6 what happens if he takes
back correct and what happens if he
recaptures C takes d5 right because now
I have more attackers than he has
defenders if he takes my bishop takes d5
and I've won upon so this turned out to
be a very very good opening for me so I
really liked creating a fortress and I
really started playing attention to the
center and developing my pieces in the
center I got to be pretty good with
white yes I even made a draw or two yes
that was really really good and then I
started to think that if the fortress
variation worked so well for me when I
was white maybe maybe I could use the
same setup
for when I was black so I wanted a
fortress I kind of thought of my
fortress position as the universal
medicine it's good against every opening
okay so we're gonna go back to the
starting position so now we have to
imagine that I'm playing the black
pieces and you know what I want to do I
want to have my knight here my pawn here
my bishop here and my King here once I
got my King to safety then I would turn
my attention to the center okay because
my pieces are on good squares play for
the center and I develop them later but
I was really worried about my King
safety so whenever my opponent opened up
Knight here for example I play Knight
here and I'm on my way to a safe King if
my opponent opened with his pawn to
doops
if you open pawn to d4 I played Knight
here sometimes my opponent would play
this and he would occupy the center but
I have King safety and then I would play
from there oftentimes my opponent for
example played Knight here and I put my
pawn in the center I'd lose a lot of
games but I'd have a safe King for a
long long while okay so nothing bothered
me my fortress work miracles except for
one move my problem when I had the black
pieces and I was starting playing chess
was when my opponent opened with this
move how many of you play e4 e to e for
that front that move was the problem
child in my fortress creation why
because if I try
to play the fortress he would attack my
knight and chase it away darn I hated
that so I got to be clever I started
with this move as my first move so that
if he played d4 I could play my fortress
variation and I was a happy camper
I was a happy camper for a long long
long time until until somebody
discovered a move that really really
hurt they would play f4 this is called
the Austrian attack by the way I didn't
know that I mean I did all I knew is
that he he put the pawns right up there
on d4 II for an f4 I play my fortress
variation Bishop g7 my opponent played
Knight f3 got my fortress yay and then I
was really shocked when my opponent
played ePHI why didn't I like that move
e5 why
it does indeed that's correct there was
something else that really bugged me it
attacked my night I'd have to move my
night and I wouldn't have a good guard
for my royal palace if I played this
move if I move my night away because it
you know what my opponents did they use
their cannons against me they would play
h4 immediately attacking my king
now that they've driven my night away I
thought that the best way to to deal
with that attack was to attack in the
center look at all of these pawns wow
that's wild isn't it well they would
continue to attack me h5 I take the pawn
on d4 they take with the Queen I bring
my knight to c6 this is a really good
move why is this a real good move so I
get to develop with a gain of tempo I
love doing that at developing my pieces
with a gain of tempo my opponent would
retreat his queen you know what I do I
capture a pawn so I thought I was doing
real well here until my opponent played
tanks now look at what's happening with
my king my Kings coming up to in to
attack and remember one of our key
principles we want safety for our king
if I take with this pawn what do I do
I weaken this diagonal which encourages
white to do what
developing with the tempo Bishop to c4
check and if the King goes into the
corner you see that cannon heaven I
moved into the range of the rook on h1
what could what could white do do you
see it
excellent move Queen to h4 makes a
double attack against the pawn on h7
since my knight isn't on f6 to defend
the pawn on h7 I'm in trouble
but even as good as a move as that is
and it's very good white had a
devastating sacrifice can you see the
devastating sacrifice the first time
this was played against me I was like
really I needed hospital care what could
he do what can he do White has a
devastating sacrifice Queen h4 is a
winning move but White has something
even more forceful more forceful can he
sacrifice a rook let's see what happens
rook takes h7 check this is what we call
a double exclamation mark move when I
say a double exclamation mark move what
does that mean yes he meant really good
we even say brilliant brilliant but I
had no choice I have to take his rook
with my king which exposes me to two
checks I could check with the Queen
or
yes Knight g5 check and if I move my
King young man oh I just got killed okay
we're gonna go back we're gonna go back
to this situation do you remember this
situation a moment ago we were here and
I have just taken this pawn I beg your
pardon and let's say after takes a
moment ago I took with the f7 pawn and I
fell into that Bishop c4 check and that
devastating rook sacrifice this time let
me take with this pawn and now how can
white attack my king
how can white attack my king you bet
Queen to h4 and now I was really afraid
of checkmate and I saw that if my knight
tried to guard the checkmate he would
recapture the pawn on e5 and my knight
would have to move again so I move my
rook to e8 to make room for my King and
now what did white do what did white
okay good good good a pattern to
remember it happens a lot
this pattern you're gonna love it can I
show you I'm anxious to show you check I
only have one move King f8 now remember
what I was saying about my Archer and
how he was of my Royal Guard a loyal and
loyal guard my best defender is the
bishop correct correct
my opponent would capture my pawn on e5
with what idea in mind is this bishop on
c1 working no it's sleeping it's
sleeping in its barracks but now this
bishop wants to come alive where will
this bishop go next where h6 to get rid
of my royal guard so you know what I did
I thought I was so clever I took with my
knight on e5 what did my opponent do yes
you bet
Bishop to h6 the best defending piece of
my king is my bishop so with this bishop
move white is trying to get rid of this
bishop now I saw that if I take the
bishop I will get checkmated how how
correct and then yes
Queen age a checkmate that's very nice
the rook supports the Queen however what
was very interesting as you did it in
two moves can you give a checkmate in
one yeah yes wow that's terrible but I
saw that oh boy was I had clever I was
so clever I saw that if I took on h6
Queen AJ checkmate
or Queen takes h6 check and checkmate on
the next turn but I had a defense I had
a real good defense - I took the night
and said check and I was very proud that
I could check my opponents king he took
my knight and checked this out you're
going to be amazed at my defensive
prowess
I played Queen to d4 with the idea to
protect my mission so I'm hoping he will
trade bishops
I'll recapture with the Queen and I'll
have stopped the attack you got to give
me credit right applause brilliant
that's how I was really really good my
opponent checkmated me in one move how
did he do that how did my opponent
checkmate me in one move I was shocked I
needed hospital care again do you see
the move do you see the move
well let's put it another way this
Bishop on g7 protects this square
correct except for one small tiny detail
that Bishop is in a pen
check mate ah I was devastated mom asked
ya sir
yeah sir how did you do you know what
Yassir had to say
I got checkmated on the kingside does it
what are you gonna get stopped getting
checkmated on the kingside I don't know
but I'm not working on it okay so we
have to go back to the very very start I
lost so many games with my fortress
variation when I was black because I
kept getting checkmated on the Kings
side because my knight that was supposed
to be guarding my King was forever
getting chased away by my opponents
pound what I mean to say was in this
position when my opponent played efore I
dread it oh I wanted my fortress
position that I dreaded that the pawn
would come to e5 so I had to be clever I
had to think how am I going to get my
fortress variation and I've got to stop
the pawn from coming to e5 well as we
saw a moment ago when white had the pawn
on d4 it was supporting the pawn on e5 I
had a solution the solution was not to
let white put-upon on d4 so what I did
is I played c5 this is what was called
the Sicilian the Sicilian defense I
didn't know that by the way my opponent
would play Knight f3 I would play knight
c6 my opponent would play d4 I would
take the pawn on d4 my opponent would
recapture now again I didn't know what
this variation was called I just knew I
wanted my fortress okay how do I get my
fork
set up so I was very happy to get rid of
this pond because I knew that once white
got a pawn on d4 that pawn on d4 s'
fortified his advanced a5 and I stopped
it before it happened now it would play
g6 my opponents would play Knight c3 I
would play Bishop g7 my opponents would
play Bishop e3 I would play Knight f6 my
opponents would play some move here I'm
not even too sure what my opponent may
be they developed their Bishop I'm not
sure they could develop their Bishop all
kinds of ways and now I had the fortress
without having to worry about the pawn
advancing and disturbing my King later
some really good chess experts you know
the guys with the 2000 ratings I mean
they were gods they said to me yes sir
you're playing the accelerated dragon
variation yes anything that was the
dragon I was happy with accelerated
dragon boy they just call me young
dragon and you know you've got the idea
so I was really pleased that I had
fallen upon this discovery of getting a
fortress position by the way in this
position have I done well have I
controlled the center my knight
are they on good squares my bishop is
good my rook is good yes is my king and
safety yes so now I could turn my
attention to the center if they did this
move castles
just like respect my opponents very good
he's put his King in safety as well now
I can turn to the center and I could
play a move like this attacking in the
sin
okay at this at this moment Black has
three pieces that are sleeping three
pieces in blacks position are sleeping
can you tell me what three pieces they
are yes in the Queen on d8 the bishop on
c8 and the rook on a they're sleeping
because they haven't moved so with this
move
d5 tanks tanks tanks tanks my Queens no
longer sleeping she's in battle my
bishop is getting ready to come out and
as soon as my bishop comes out this rook
will come out I did well I lost him
another 25 moves but I was at least from
the opening I did well so the whole
thing about this class is three things
in the opening you want to play for
control of the center principle number
one principle number two you need good
peat squares for your pieces and you
need a safe king you do that you're on
your way to losing lots of games but but
but you'll be in a fight your opponent
won't checkmate you in five moves like I
do you see me get checkmate
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]